persia les cela c'est une autre affaire
philippe dumais ce jeu confirmé
en ville c'est avec une certaine émotion
que les habitants de kourou ont suivi ce
tir parfaitement réussi en dépit de la
pluie qui a empêché de pouvoir suivre la
fusée ariane
à l'extérieur on l'a simplement entendu
passer je ressens certainement la même
émotion que
le public qui a travaillé là dessus car
je vis ici depuis deux ans et je pense
que si joli si c'est parce que j'aime
et des constructions d'édifices
coloniaux argent une ariane pour lancer
des satellites des puits dont qu'ils ont
bien des problèmes au niveau des n'avait
ni donc sa concurrence quant à m ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce vol va enlever les
dernières réticences envers un produit
qui ne vient pas des états unis l'europe
spatiale vient de passer de l'espoir à
la réalité et devient compétitif
oui nous l'étions déjà comparé aux
fusées classique de nos concurrents mais
maintenant si nous pouvons continuer à
améliorer cette fusée est bien nous
deviendrons vraiment tout à fait
continuer sur le marché pour toutes
sortes de satellites mais surtout pour
les satellites géostationnaires puisque
séoul et cesser d'être idiot ça c'est
rien que nous avons surtout confié cette
fusée rien on est filmé le marché
mondial des satellites géostationnaires
civile à construire et donc à lancer
dans l'espace à 200 environ pour les dix
prochaines années et ariane pourrait
dans lance et une soixantaine le
prochain tir aura lieu en avril 80 2